hello everybody
welcome to an impromptu
live h3 podcast ela has joined us
despite saying she would never join us
[Applause]
despite being on a million hormones so
i apologize in advance what are you
apologizing for
for whatever may come you just might get
a little
temperamental yes yeah we've been doing
um
filling on edge today all kinds of um
fertility stuff trying to get either
a biscuit in the uh
no no food um allegories allegories
no food please when talking about
getting pregnant
do not use oh you don't like the the bun
and the man or any of that
not today okay not today well i don't
know if you guys heard but it's been
pretty serious we've i've been
injecting elo with shots of hormones in
her stomach
every day my my stomach is so bruised
like
i can't can't move right you're like a
junkie your stomach
and you guys know that scene from pulp
fiction where she stabs the needle in
the chest
so that's what i'm doing to ela
basically every night
no but that you know it's really painful
too it like burns but
um we're almost through it and hopefully
we get another little uh
shrimp out of it don't worry you're
always wonderful beautiful
the greatest of all time and you look
good what do you think you got like a
thing in your hair with a flower
yeah damn and what's this this is sick
too what is this
the wrist oh that's nice it's hot i like
the checkers it's amazing that's hot
we love we stand hila no matter how many
hor whatever
is going through your body whatever
level of estrogen is going on
obviously we come here today um on short
noted or like
usually we film today and then post it
tomorrow
we're doing today's live because there
was
this uh bombshell article
about david dobreck and the vlog squad
where um by
insider where
um
this blows everything out of the water
that we've talked about it's really
disturbing i knew this article was
coming out
but it was way more in depth and the
gravity of the
of the accusations in this article was
way more than i expected
yeah so according to this article which
we'll read
we're also having the author call in
afterwards to help us
get us clarity on everything and david's
also
issued an apology or an i don't know if
you go it's like an apology slash
it's more like a legal disclaimer i
don't know what it was
um yeah pretty nice so we're covering
there's a lot to cover we're going to
cover all of it
but in this article it alleges that
in one of david's vlogs which featured
this guy
dom there was a
an r word took place
an essay slash r word
does everyone understand what you're
talking about okay it feels so silly i
have to be careful
on this live i don't want it right you
know you got to be careful but i think
everyone knows what i'm saying
so there was an essay during one of his
vlogs
in which there was a plot about this guy
dom
having you know relationships yeah
relations with five girls right
and so he put in his video
a straight up s a slash r word so
um there it's the whole story and
everything surrounding it is really
uh incredible in the in the obviously
tragic sense
of the word but it really underlies just
how responsible
irresponsible david is in making i mean
that that puts it lightly
you know yeah i'm gonna read the article
because i think it's um really important
there's a lot of really good details in
it that i think
deserve to be shared you know it was
behind a paywall so i was like ugh
why they got to do that i get it i know
they got to make money and it's hard
making it and like print
journalism and [ __ ] and like they had
lawyers they were on with david's lawyer
it's an expensive article to put
together
it's kind of true you forget that
they have to make money somehow it's not
easy and
um we've got
we're getting used to getting everything
for free i don't know what to think
about it because i got upset when i was
like this is way too important to put
behind a bay wall
but it's like you want them to do really
good research right you want them to do
lawyers spend money on it and no
i don't know yeah but
look at any rate even if a lot of people
haven't read it
um the word is out and i'm gonna pirate
it here
live on the podcast
i'm just kidding this is fair use
because i'm reporting on it
right verbatim and commenting on it but
the author's calling in so i mean can it
be pirating if the author's calling in
to talk about it
yes yes it could be no
i got david and insider to deal with no
oh you know what else something exciting
exciting before we got get into the
article we got swatted yesterday
hey
third time we got swatted first time at
the new house
it's so upsetting just right after my
mom arrived
um yeah they there's always these really
suspicious timing with the swatting that
like
the last time we got swatted we were
coming back from new york with theodore
yeah so i was like oh they're trying to
you know
they're trying to catch us with theodore
it's like wow that's pretty sinister
and this time we her mom arrived
yesterday and then again we get swatted
it's like
they're trying to find these horrible
moments to do it
i obviously don't know who did it the
last time it happened
they got arrested though so like i'm
still getting letters from the
department of justice about this guy's
trial so i
i'm surprised people think that this is
a safe activity to do because
they for they're finding these people
now yeah
i don't know i don't know why i don't
know what makes a person want to do that
because i just really wonder do they not
understand the severity of what they're
doing or they do they're being
no they're very malicious they're that
malicious and they know exactly what to
say like
the cops showed up there was like six so
the city knows that
we live at this address which is great
so when the police were coming
unlike previous times dispatch was like
hey there's a youtuber that lives there
that's been swatted before
so that's good and now because we're in
a gated community
they said you know we were a little
suspicious about the call because
usually when there's shots fired you get
more than one call
and we got to talk to the guard and he
says he you know
nothing happened so at least this time
their guns weren't drawn
like the previous two times the previous
two times were nuts man they were like
doing perimeter sweeps with like assault
rifles drawn there was helicopters in
with spotlights this time there was like
six cops in front of the
house and they were slamming on the
doors like what the hell is going on
this mailman got a new
package what's up with this amazon
delivery
these guys lost their damn mind yeah
and then we have like a glass door so i
saw all the cops and i was like okay
here we go
i go out to meet them and um they were
nice i mean they were great
they were very nice and they're very
helpful they gave me good advice too
going forward if it happens again
they gave me the police report and they
said just come out with the police
report and your id
so that you'd be like yo i got swatted
it's all good they can see immediately
but you know these cops were nice and
understanding and got the memo but you
you just you never know who's gonna show
up or what's going on in their day
i mean people have died getting swatted
it's just not a nice thing well not to
mention the trauma
it's horrible i mean last time i got
swatted shredder got out we thought he'd
shred her i'd like
you know shredder's aggressive cops
don't like aggressive dogs
no yeah it was all i will never forget
that
i also think shredder has been
traumatized ever since i know every time
he hears like police chatter on a tv
show or something he
panics um and then
yeah it's whatever i don't know i don't
even want to shout out
whoever did that um the cops are really
nice
and you'll probably be arrested because
that's what happened to the last people
that did it
so i look forward to getting a
department of justice letter on behalf
of whoever did that
right i don't know who i don't know if
it had anything to do with the david
dobrik thing i doubt it i don't think so
the last people who did it were like can
you imagine well i don't think david or
anyone who knows
no i don't know but like his fans yeah i
mean the last people who did it were
like white supremacists
right they're part of like some white
supremacist neo-nazi group
so i assume it's probably
something to do with that because who
else would be that malicious you know
other than like like that
um one other update friday is our live
show
is our i just want to announce this
because it's we um
the coin are extra rare vape niche gold
coin one of one
is ending live on the show friday and so
i just want to make sure everybody knows
this is going to be thrilling
exciting times
let the bidding begin everybody the vape
nation video one of one
woo hoo
[Music]
uh i'm trying to see
i'm gonna i'm gonna have to donate a lot
to like environmental because everyone's
angry
apparently nft's like burn the earth so
i'm gonna give some to like
i don't know uh smokey the bear or who
who who can i give it to uh
i'll upgrade smokey's cave
get him some pimp out his cave can you
overall
new overalls he's gonna be pimped out
bro he's gonna be blinged out like gucci
overalls and [ __ ] he's like what's up
swag out his forest
anyway um oh there you know last night
are there no sponsors there's no sponsor
okay i didn't want to put a sponsor
got it today's episode is sponsored by
yeah well you know you never know but i
i intentionally didn't put anything
okay yeah thank you
oh there's just one other thing that i
wanted to talk about first
you know i was watching there's this
documentary on netflix about the college
admissions scandal that came out last
night i was watching it
really good i didn't know this olivia
jade
was like the reason this whole thing got
busted open
really yes because she said something no
so and by the way the documentary proves
because there's always questions of like
oh does she know does the dad know
they all knew there was text messages
between them all three of them talking
that they showed
they all knew and one of the guidance
like so
this was in my high school when people
get into college there's like they put
these like
congratulations on the wall like
congratulations ethan was going to ucsc
and so jade and her sister both got into
usc
and people are like oh that's weird
because usc is like really hard to get
into and apparently they're like
not great students and they're like
that's so
odd the guidance counselor thought it
was so odd
that he called usc to inquire
oh my god because it's because he looked
into it and she got admitted for being
some kind of like
backup for the row team and he's like
this is weird
so he calls the usc uh like athletics or
admission department and he goes what's
the deal with how did she get into usc
and they're like oh she's part of our
athletics program and he's like well
just so you know
she's never rode she doesn't row or any
of that [ __ ]
wow and apparently like their whole
family
knew that this guidance counselor was
causing trouble and so like he her dad
went there
and like was was like trying to
intimidate him to drop it and she said
oh my god
yeah wow it's really interesting the
documentary wait wasn't that
isn't the dad the the big fashion
designer yeah he's a famous designer
yeah so like i cannot get over this
story
who cares so much about getting into i
know
yeah and it's always about the pa so
like
when you're that rich and you're in this
high status of social circles
it's like oh my college got into my my
son is going to harvard
it's like ooh it's like a flex under
their parents mm-hmm
even though the shitty parents they got
to prove somehow that they've raised
their kids right
that's crazy because olivia didn't even
want to go
like she was killing it on youtube she's
like i don't give a [ __ ] about usc
but the parents insisted she go and
bought her in crazy right
and some of these parents were spending
like a million and a half dollars
to get their million and a half [ __ ]
that you're dumb ass kid
i can't i mean and she's not even well
equipped to go through the rigors of a
of like a a high tier elite
college like olivia jade got there and
she's like i [ __ ] hate it i can't
deal with this [ __ ]
you know what i mean like you have to be
prepared to deal with the rigors of
of uh i mean yeah she was already having
a cool
popping channel on youtube exactly
just let her do what she wants yeah
there was a huge part about olivier
jaden family that was really interesting
anyway just wanted to talk about that
you want to talk about teddy fresh on
thursday or no
no teddy fresh on thursday you do that
talking
oh well there's a new drop on teddy
fresh this tomorrow
so that's it check it out they'll be
[ __ ] on the website
10 a.m all right all right we got a lot
to get to here yeah
oh another interesting thing about david
before we get started is you know
the whole time that me and trisha have
been going on about this
he seemed like people just didn't care
it was unaffected but now all of a
sudden
he's been trending on youtube since his
article came out and people are actually
unsubbing
which i never expected actually to
happen on his channel he lost 100
000 subscribers today just find it
interesting that now
oh you know what it was he made the
video and when he makes the video he
clues all the people in
and then they go what the [ __ ] because
majority people who watch that video on
his
his apology video probably had no idea
what the hell
something was even going on i think it's
also the fact that it's an
article and it's not just other
youtubers talking about it sure because
for someone from the outside it may seem
like who
who's real who's not you know it may
seem like a big for drama
yeah like hard to understand and hard to
follow yeah
people think any time trisha they just
well trisha just
just has a vendetta against david so
they dismiss everything she says
funnily enough trisha has proven to be
completely right about everything in
this situation
completely wow thank you you're welcome
you're welcome
i have to say i stand trishy yeah i mean
conducting herself quite well
i'm impressed with her yeah
can i say i like her she's my sister
thank you so crazy she's coming over on
friday to have a whole family shebang
she's eating she's gonna meet eva's mom
oh that's a big deal
it's it's awesome it's crazy but it's
awesome i'm happy yeah everyone's happy
she's cool
the way things started and where we are
now is the whole
life comes at you fast dude you never
know what the hell is around the next
turn
okay boomer okay settle down i'm trying
to do a show here
what's up with trisha insulting me she's
not even here
i saw she posted on instagram or
something that um
it was like just last week was one year
since she had met
yesterday oh wow
seems both seems longer than that right
kind of
like 20 20 was a long year it was a long
and we were doing that
yeah it was just the beginning of kovit
we're doing the bachelor with tricia
yeah that was a long mother effing time
ago
all right let's get into it now guys
this might feel tedious at times i'm
going to try to
there's a lot of background information
stuff i'm trying to skip but i do want
to do it justice because this article is
so well written and it's so well sourced
they did such a professional and good
job
and by the way like dude they got the
receipts like the the main source of
this article is this girl
who was the victim of the essay and she
has a lot of there's a lot of supporting
evidence here like pictures and videos
and dms and stuff that
she all shared with insider to the point
where i don't think anyone is even
trying to deny
or discredit that this happened right
i haven't seen anyone really trying to
even question it right
yeah which is really interesting and
unusual
yeah it's up to this point it's been a
battle of like oh
this and that and david denver wouldn't
do david doesn't have a bad bone in his
body
he's just disappointed yeah
so that's so they they they crush i mean
this article is just they crushed it on
the
journalistic side of it
okay here we go and yes i did buy a
membership
we did it i wanted to do it right at
least you know if i'm if i'm going to
pirate it for everybody here at least
i paid for it can we not use the word
pirates
i'm kidding it's not a pirate i'm a
journal i'm as a journalist i'm sure i'm
talk i'm commenting on a
current event covered by fair use damn
it
okay so the title is a woman featured on
youtube star david dobrik's channel says
she was r-worded
by a vlog squad member in 2018 the night
they filmed a video about group sex
yeah that's quite a title why the title
when i read that title i was like holy
[ __ ]
i thought the article was just about
like that they supplied
minors with alcohol for their videos but
this was like oh my god
i'm gonna say there's a lot of
background stuff it is a really long
article
they were just saying just giving
background on the vlog squad and stuff
and the girls
the girls uh let's see
she's a college student they're in their
20s you know they're going to meet a
bunch of like
famous youtubers and have a fun time
she's 20 year old yeah she's 20. it
seems like they weren't even sure
they're like is this real is this set up
do we real are we really supposed to
have sex with them you know what i mean
someone asked the sexy stuff won't be in
the vlog right
anyway yada yada i'm just trying to find
there was a point here where i wanted to
start then there's like all the attorney
stuff why it's like the more i move the
less
you don't have to have it on that screen
just so you know
it's easier to just read it off yeah i
can just show it on my computer oh
it's okay i like to see it like this
okay fair enough
um
she the girl who is the main source of
the spoke with insider on the condition
of
an anime anonymity
anonymity this is not about how you
cannot pronounce words ethan
get your word straight jack joe biden
an animated anonymity out of concerns of
sharing her full name could affect
employment opportunities so they've so
her
identity is concealed we have the vlog
that this is from we we censor or or
blurred all the faces of the girls too
to protect our identity
uh uh david's attorney
released this statement he said david
will be addressing his community
directly
which is interesting it really says a
lot about the apologies that like this
was planned in coordination with his pr
and attorneys
the statement went on to say anyone who
knows him knows he does not condone
misconduct in any form vlogbroth
vlog squad percep participants provide
consent before anything is posted
whenever consent is retracted
posts are removed any insinuation of
wrongdoing is accurate and defamatory
okay
but i love that already that the
statement from attorney says anyone who
knows david
knows yeah this uh this is not he
doesn't condone it's like this was
scotty's defense the
anyone who knows him defense what kind
of lawyer would say that
i don't know i mean it's like such a
sneaky way to defend anyone try saying
that to the judge
anyone didn't judge anyone that knows
david
yeah exactly it's like the remember the
chewbacca defense from south park
this is chewbacca okay you remember that
[ __ ]
chewbacca is a whoopie for mentor
it's been a while since i thought about
that
um anyway this is where i want to start
from so i guess hannah is as
is as soon as uh you know yeah yeah
so hannah says she quickly felt
uncomfortable with the vlog squad
members i guess i should give a trigger
warning
that there is going to be some
uncomfortable essay
discussion talking about at this point
so i'm going to read the whole thing so
buckle in it might get a little tedious
but
this is it the video filmed the night
hannah says she was assaulted follows a
classic
dobrick vlog format it's four minutes
and 20 seconds long and includes a
celebrity cameo and comedy scenes
featuring dobik's friends do you know
how to say this name
zeg zegliatis it's like glyphosate
i'm just going to say dom here here
forever here
known as dom from here forth known as
dom
dom appears 2 minutes and 13 seconds in
according to a copy of the video
reviewed by insider
i invited these girls over to have a
five some he says
implying that he'll have sex with four
women at once so hopefully i'll have a
five some tonight
the next shot is of hannah and her
friends walking into the apartment on
hollywood and highland where dobrik
dom and other vlog squad members are
gathered as soon as she walked in the
door hannah said someone shoved the
camera in her face
she has one line of dialogue in the
video as she and her friend sit on the
couch
hannah is heard saying she doesn't
actually know anyone who is in the vlog
squad
get the [ __ ] out vlog squad member jason
nationals in response as everyone laughs
in real life hannah says she didn't find
the banter funny at one point she said
nash who was 45 at the time made a
comment along the lines of oh you have a
personality hot girls
like you usually don't i immediately
felt really uncomfortable because i was
under the impression that we were going
to meet these cool creators
we were going to hang out maybe film
something hannah told insider
it was high pressure from the moment we
walked in well i
certainly believe that having you know
what i mean like that's for sure true
because they i think they thought they
were coming to have a good time but
david was there to make a video
yeah that's kind of the whole
premise here is like everyone is this is
all just for content
hannah and her friend sarah who drove
everyone to the apartment told insider
that they never intended to have group
sex with
dom that night a hesitance reflected in
the vlog
in his voice over dobrik says after a
couple of minutes of talking it was
clear that no fivesome was happening
but dobrek added by some stroke of luck
and master negotiating
dom made progress which is
insane a little sinister i i think i
think we should watch it at this point
because i have this part on tape
yeah and um
i think it's it's better to just watch
it let me see here i've got it
master negotiating yeah that sounds like
that's like a nice euphemism for like
cowards and girls to sleep with you
um here's the video where we censored
the faces
of the girls involved these girls over
to have a five some so hopefully i have
five some tonight
[Music]
is
[Laughter]
after a couple minutes of talking it was
clear there was no fivesome happening
tonight he called it
yeah you guys want to watch me and
trisha have sex
i'm bound but by some stroke of luck and
master negotiating dom made progress
that's so creepy that's like just after
like
knowing what we know after reading the
whole article it's
just it makes me sick
it makes my stomach you know he put this
all in so it's like
they definitely so he goes it's just
amazing that he put that there
yeah he goes they did not want to have
sex with him but
after a bunch of alcohol and coercion
dom was able to get him in the room
against their will basically
against their stated desire when they
entered
and by the way now i've learned that
this dom
guy had already had sexual yeah
allegations yeah he's a creep against
him
he's we'll get into that but yeah this
guy's a little this guy's twisted
and you'll find that you know david kind
of made it a plot point in his vlog
like he created this whole situation
to see how dom would react
hoping that you know it would create
content for his vlog
we just need to get in there and do a
head count for the vlog okay
yeah so they skip a lot here we'll get
into that but this is like
hours later so they're him and a few
girls are in there
you know having relations and the guys
go in there without asking permission
and sneak
start watching for the vlog they go oh
we need a head count for the vlog
okay all right we got we got three in
there
jonah's gonna peek in so he can describe
it to me a bunch
well everybody's looking in i'm gonna
have to leave the apartment
i'm kind of getting horny just like
listening to this okay i open the door
i know it's just a frat house it's just
like you know what i mean
it's a total boys club frat house
holy [ __ ] it smells like someone was
murdered in here
what's up dude you are sweating
like a racehorse was that your first
threesome yeah
so again i noticed something really
interesting why does he think david
was that your first threesome yes it was
thank you david
so why is he thanking dave what is he
thanking david for
arranging the situation in which he
could the girls
from what i understand um not
not the main the victim was not a fan
she didn't know
who david is but the rest were fans of
david right
so they just wanted to meet david he set
it up he made it possible
he made it possible for sure i mean look
you think
david case closed
the old smell my finger
smells like bread and sister
anyway there you go so that's the video
and then there's the
statement at the end all right yeah
there's you almost missed like the best
part
john just had a threesome and i think
we're all going to jail
yeah dom just had a threesome and we're
all going to jail
why are you going to jail exactly i mean
you know
if they knew something was messed up
there
why are you guys all going to jail
so
anyway they so as we'll read the article
you'll see how much they cut out
and how he managed to cut it into this
kind of
fun consensual experience that was just
everyone was having a good time
and to what really happened which was
very dark and messed up
and traumatic and was basically you know
essay
right so let's read let's continue
reading
um hannah told insider she felt
pressured by dom
and the other vlog squad members into
helping them create content that
objectified her
she said dom took turns interacting with
hannah and her friends
and then he pulled her onto his lap at
one point asking
without asking permission it was very
much an environment where it felt like
saying no was not okay hannah said
it felt like from the moment we came
there there was an expectation that they
were doing us a favor and we had to give
them content
they were verbally like why aren't you
guys being fun do something sort of sexy
anna said dom started calling her baby
and asking her if she wanted to be
his instagram girlfriend she said dom
told her she could make ten thousand
dollars a week and become famous if she
agreed
but hannah says she declined and dom
briefly seemed to move on from her as
the night went on hannah says don became
aggressive
now this is something dom's known for
previously he
apologized for like groping girls at
vidcon
and had to make an apology you know this
is
this is his shtick
if that's a schtick being a basically a
predator
a while later hannah said dom approached
her again and asked if he could talk to
her she agreed and dom led her
out of the room with her friends down an
alleyway
and into a pitch dark bedroom hannah
said dom
guided her in through the door and she
said she quickly turned around
and told him that she wanted to go back
to where friends were but don blocked
the exit with his body
hannah said and started asking her why
she didn't like him
and wouldn't date him hannah said dom
asked if they could hook up
she said no he was like no you are at
least gonna have to give me a kiss
hannah said i was getting really scared
because he wasn't letting me leave
and my friends were in a totally
different part of the house so i said
what happens if i keep saying no so i
gave him a kiss
she returned to where her friends were
sitting and she said
she said and turned around
and around that time she said a couple
members of the vlog squad returned with
a bottle of dark
colored liquor trisha paytas a former
vlog squad member told insider she was
at the apartment for about 45 minutes
that night
with hannah and her friends paytas said
the night was not a good situation
she said she left because the women were
drinking while under age which felt
insane to her
pedes also said the woman made it clear
they did not want to have group sex with
dom
they were like oh [ __ ] we're here but we
don't want to have sex peda said
pedes told insider the vlog squad jeff
whittick
went to go buy liquor for the party
after she told nash
her boyfriend at the time not to pedes
said she
and nash left before whittak got back
yeah i mean that's all supported in the
in the vlog also there's there's video
from trisha's vlog that shows that
she left before oh yeah that's in the
document
it's funny they're trying to discredit
that's all trisha's they the
david's lawyers who tried to like be
like you can't print this because trish
is one of your sources and she's
she has a mental illness it's like she's
in the video
they cite her such a small amount um
and it's everything she says is totally
supported by the video evidence you know
and by the way jason you're probably
pretty happy that your crazy girlfriend
commits you to leave the party now yeah
yikes of course trish is the only one
with sense in that room
[Applause]
i think this is a part that david's
lawyers made them right betas and
national no longer dating and she has
frequently criticized dobrick and
national social media including for what
she claims is a pattern of behavior that
exploits young women
she also made a tick tock stating that
she once crashed her car into nash's
house while high on meth
well worth standing i guess
david dobrik's fans have questioned paid
us credibility including by citing her
history of negative posts about
delbrick and ash
there's a whole argument maybe i'll pull
this up at this point
trisha and this guy date uh what's his
name um
whitake just jeff whitake
they were getting into it on twitter
which i'll pull up
arguing about because he said i didn't
bring the alcohol he said i was only
there for 15 minutes but like you can
see him looking in the room
which was apparently hours later so
that doesn't make sense um
trying to find a it's at the top of the
dock
yeah thank you here's the exchange this
just happened of
jeff's response basically to the
allegation that he was the one that
bought the alcohol
trisha said david you really just tried
to shift all the blame on domi's you
sick [ __ ] jeff and todd went all bought
alcohol for the girls to [ __ ]
vlog shows them not into it and then
cuts to them having sex
jeff responded he said we didn't buy
anything for anyone i willingly called
that reporter because i know i'm
innocent in this situation
i'm not perfect but i 100 didn't do what
you're accusing me of
and i'm willing to go to any extent to
prove it i mean i don't know what extent
you could possibly go to but
how do you explain underage girls
getting the alcohol where do you explain
how the girls had a change of heart as
david said in the vlog
what was the convincing that happened
you guys were there at the start of the
vlog and the end
exactly he said i can't explain what i
don't know i was there for 15 minutes
i i got it i mean listen you were there
at the beginning of the end like tricia
said so that explanation of 15 minutes
doesn't quite make sense
all i know is what you and only you are
accusing me of is false
maybe dom bought it maybe you did maybe
one of the girls did i'm just saying it
definitely wasn't me or todd nobody told
me [ __ ] i thought it was a conceptual
bit
sorry i didn't say hi at the starbucks
that one time apparently apparently he
thinks that's
i don't know what's the story with that
a.b
does he think that's why trisha hates
him well
i supposedly yeah they ran into each
other at a starbucks and uh
he didn't say hi and then trisha made a
video calling him out
yeah that sounds like trisha you should
have said hi
i agree
not the worst crime in this article
though
yeah far from the uh i worst crime
missing details
so i'm just recalling from what i've
seen a few years ago so
nobody be mad anyway just just to give
jeff a fair shake here i'm just going to
read his statement he says his heart
goes out to the victim i'm truly sorry
you're in the situation
um the disgusting action dom had
committed to you
i absolutely do not condone i've done a
lot of dumb [ __ ] in my life but if i was
in the room and a girl was being
assaulted i would absolutely never
let that happen my involvement in the
video was under depression was
consensual i have absolutely nothing to
do with nor any influence with this
disgusting act nor did i purchase or
allow this to happen
purchase alcohol i have tremendous
respect for all the women for all women
it would not let any action like this
happen to anyone with much love and
respect
i mean like i just need to get this one
medicine
and i kind of need to do it right now
you gotta go right now is it
i just need to like be on my phone for a
second oh sure okay
yeah i just didn't want to seem weird
it's okay i'm glad you explained it okay
i don't know what to make of this like
how much blame do all the guys
there have i mean jeff looked in the
room he said i have to check for the
vlog
i don't know i mean excluding the whole
buying alcohol thing
anyway let's continue
hannah's friend sarah who said she
didn't drink that night because she was
driving
told insider she remembers todd asking
the group what kind of alcohol people
wanted
i mean sarah also said she remembers
smith and whitak coming back to the
apartment with smith
holding a bottle of jack daniel's
whiskey oh well then
that's the sober friend and that's a
second detail in his tweets that just
got he said that trisha is the only one
accusing him of that it sounds like
that's not true
yeah the sober friend is is directly
calling him out for it
so that's two things that he tweeted
that are directly contradicted
uh trisha says it was that dope uh
david's direction to go
and remember these girls are underage
they're they're not of drinking age
sarah shared a photo with insider oh
sarah the sober friend shared a photo
with insider of dom sitting with hannah
and her friend alongside a bottle of
jack daniel whiskey
and a two liter bottle of pepsi that's
what i'm saying they've got the [ __ ]
receipts
they do they have receipts for
everything in this story
so they were drinking and they were
underage you know
someone bought it i guess we'll never i
mean according to her it was them
and they were clearly trying to get
footage of
them having sex yeah which he walked
it's like the theme of the vlog
that was the whole thing and that is
known for a fact the fact that they were
drinking
is got backup and receipts so it's it's
hard to argue man this is like a really
well
it isn't an argument really and a phone
call with insider whitak
denied buying the alcohol and said he
didn't think that smith would have
bought it either
though he admits that smith loves
whiskey
interesting uh good thing to mention
there jeff
well it sounds like if it was anyone it
was this guy todd because sarah said
he's the one that was asking people what
they wanted to drink but okay whatever
who knows
at this point i can't really remember
much hannah said i just remember being
really uncomfortable
and being honestly really upset and
angry that my friend thought these guys
were cool
and that they were really just
objectifying and gross
this is todd i think right yeah this is
todd
the guy this is the guy she's saying
brought the whiskey
hannah's friend says that dom had sex
with her
while she was blacked out
hannah said she drank so much alcohol
that night that she filled the
she filmed with the vlog squad that
she filmed with the vlog squad that she
blocked she bla
she blacked out sarah told insider that
hannah wanted to go to dom's room with
dom and their friend audrey though sarah
said she could tell that hannah was
drunk she was comfortable with letting
her go into the room because hannah
wouldn't be alone with
dom i just remember seeing her and dom
talking a lot added sarah
who said hannah and dom were both
drinking they were both on the floor and
definitely a lot of alcohol is being
exchanged and kind of like nudging
toward her
there are definitely times when she was
drinking on her own but there were also
times when he was clearly trying to get
her
more drunk sarah said hannah was able to
walk into the room
but that she could tell hannah was drunk
because she was started excessively and
expressing abstract thoughts
things that sarah said hannah usually
did when she was drunk
she was not fully coherent and
articulate sarah said
you could tell she was definitely
affected by something it was very
obvious in the way she was speaking
which was very fast and a lot
once hannah and audrey were in the room
with with
dom sarah said the other vlog squad
members
started listening in some of them even
opened the door to look at what was
happening sarah said
in retrospect she thought it was
disgusting that people were watching
again that's in the video
once again so can't dispute that
obviously she did not consent to the act
itself but she especially did not
consent to having multiple men peeking
in their heads
to confirm what was happening by the way
recall them being like oh i'm getting
horny they look good
he says they look good it's like okay
sarah said sarah said that uh dom locked
the door to the bedroom at one point
while he was having sex to stop the vlog
sweat members from coming in
sarah said dobrick was among the vlog
sword members trying to look into the
room
she shared a video of dobrik she took
that night with insider in which dobre
can see
can be seen responding to someone asking
if he found success in getting into the
room with
dom hannah and audrey no he locked the
door
dobre responds in the video cameron
hands again like
receipts are crazy she filmed this
showed it to insider
i mean they really saved this [ __ ]
which i think just goes to show how
messed up they knew it was even in that
moment that they were like
still have this stuff on hand sarah said
that
dom and audrey came out of the room
first and that sarah
went in after him to find hannah laying
limp on the bed
sarah said she was immediately concerned
and that she remembered hannah tugging
on her ear and asking where her earrings
was
hannah said she does not remember having
sex with dom and that audrey told her
dom performed sexual acts on her that
were penetrative
specifically hannah and audrey told her
that dom was having sex with hannah and
didn't stop as hannah showed sides of
losing consciousness
so audrey took over to get dom to stop
audrey declined to comment but in a text
she sent to hannah this month about
their night with
dom she wrote i remember you were
starting to close your eyes and you were
obviously so drunk
i finished him off just to get him away
from you
after dom finished hannah said she was
too drunk to dress herself
what i do remember is lying on the bed
in that room alone and my roommate at
the time coming in and being super
worried about putting my underwear on me
because i couldn't do that by myself
that is disturbing yeah and like
especially when you remember how they
reacted afterwards how he's all covered
in sweat
and they're like whoa thank you david
so this is her ring and
i've been blackout drunk i know what
it's like
you you don't remember anything yeah and
i mean
it's an awful feeling the next morning
because you're like
you don't know what happened to you and
being around people that drunk it's like
they're basically in a coma i mean yeah
like you're they're not
it's not a it's very clearly not a
consensual exchange
and you can tell based on that
interaction with dom that he wasn't
he didn't appear to be that drunk yeah
he seems very
like fairly coherent i mean yeah very
coherent in that clip
um sarah said that she and hannah's
roommate took her
into dom's bathroom where hannah
couldn't stand up or sit on the toilet
by herself
sarah said hannah fell over and passed
out on the bathroom floor briefly
and when hannah's friend pulled her back
up sarah said they had to pull
trig that sling first forcing someone to
vomit i've never heard that before
paul trigg oh pull the trigger
she pulled trigg i guess never heard
that one
she did now they explain the the the
penal code defining the r word i mean
whatever
yadda yadda basically if a person is um
not able to give consent that is yeah
i think we all understand that to be
true at this point but yeah the person
is if a person is prevented from
resisting by
by being intoxicated or any controlled
substance this condition is known or
recently should have been known by the
accused
hannah never contacted the police and no
charges were ever filed
against dom after hannah threw up sarah
and her friends had to physically
support hannah's body as they exited the
apartment
sarah shared a photo with insider she
says was taken that night that shows
hannah leaning against one of their
other friends
outside the apartment dobrick uh
smith whitaker and anton
are visible in the picture in the
background again recedes
out the sarah ears she watched dobrik's
tesla pull out the apartment building as
she walked with hannah back to her car
so he's out when the funds
when the vlog is done david got the
footage
he's out sarah said hannah started to
vomit again back at their dorm when she
finally got hannah
into her bed sarah said she started
asking questions about what had happened
dread started to seep in sarah said when
hannah didn't seem to remember leaving
campus at all
the next morning hannah said she woke up
and still felt extremely drunk
when she looked at her phone she saw a
text conversation with
uh dom and photos from the night before
she texted him that anything at your
discretion is okay for the vlog just
maybe not anything for future employment
could use against me
hannah said she still had no memory of
having sex the night before then her
friend
woke up and sarah said she told hannah
for a second time
that dom had sex with her that's when i
started internally freaking out because
it's concerning enough that the first
time she didn't remember it
the second time was really scary
what is she talking about the first and
second time because she told her
already one time and i think she was
still kind of drunk so she didn't even
remember
that she told her i see yeah so she had
to tell her again
got it when she finally started to
process the scope of what had been
happened to her hannah said she tried to
laugh it off for two days dobrek didn't
post any of the footage of her of that
night
uh and she said she tried not to think
about it then on november 28th the vlog
came out
you know you would think that these guys
would understand the gravity that like
this girl was blackout drunk puking
and that to even try to edit that into
some fun loving
vlog just seems so
it's just they it should have been
apparent to them that
that was not okay at the post i mean
it's crazy
and then with the guys peeking in
everything i mean i i just i don't get
it
and they're so young she's just 20.
hannah says she struggled to process the
footage in dobrik's vlog
and the vlog that featured hannah the
bit around the threesome include scenes
that sarah said were shot that night as
well as scenes sarah said she thought
was re-shot
but made to look like it occurred that
night in the scene shot as the sex was
occurring dobrick and vlog squad members
smith whittick antonion
ernst and calvillo joke about uh dom
having sex with hannah and audrey
and one scene whitake is standing in the
hallway outside of dom's room
and says we need to get in there to get
a head count for the vlog
whitake opens the door and tells dobrik
there are three people in the room then
anton anton and tanyan opens the door
and says oh
my god antonio i don't know i think
yeah antonio oh my god while dobrick
laughs smith said i'm kind of getting
horny just listening to this
in the form bro keep that to yourself
jesus christ dude
not charming creepy
so not so not of something to share
dude i'm thinking about going in there
taking a turn vibes
it just makes you sick i don't know what
to say
yeah someone said it's like a cat like
oh dude i can't
you know i never really followed david i
was obviously aware i've seen a few
vlogs and i knew he was like a talented
guy
talented videographer yeah i mean
putting together
i've seen some of them in the beginning
and i thought it was really cool
but how is this family friendly this is
like straight up some casting couch [ __ ]
like
this is like one little skip away from
being
you know cast like bang bang [ __ ] yeah
it's important
yeah i was the one that said that i'm
the same i knew of
who he was but i really wasn't familiar
with this guy's [ __ ] kids
yeah and i i'm not family friendly
apparently but this
is i don't know what it is maybe it's
the i think it's more more than anything
not the content it's the controversy
because before he was kind of free of
controversy
even though he's basically making
casting couch videos
and the next seed uh in the next scene
dom is standing in his room drenched in
sweat which we saw
sarah said she don't believe this scene
was shot while she and hannah were at
the apartment
right and that dom wasn't actually
dripping sweat that night
it kind of looked like it was set up
like why would he be so sweaty like i
could totally see david like putting
water on
on him and then because maybe they
needed to like
fix the plot so it looks like he just
came out of the room it was fun
it wasn't like a drunk girl puking who
was blacked out drunk
it was a fun experience where everyone
had a good time
todd says thanks david and gives him a
high five after dobrik asked if it was
his first threesome
then dom asks ernst to smell his finger
and iron says the finger smells like
brandon's sister
at the end of the vlog dobrick films
himself smith and calvillo
in the car we watch this they laugh and
say you know they're going to jail
see you in 20 years again they come with
more receipts and a podcast interview
with travis mills recorded the day the
vlog with hannah was posted
dobrick will call dom inviting the women
over for a staged
fivesome when they all got there they
were like oh no i don't want to have sex
i just i don't want to have sex dobrik
told mills except two of the girls
wanted to have sex so he ended up having
a threesome which was still his first
threesome
was all very exciting for him mills
asked if the other vlog squad members
peeked into the room to confirm
that dom was having sex with two women
and they were depict as they were
depicted in the vlog and delbrick said
yeah well
you know he didn't have sex with them
unless we saw it with our own eyes
i have that here i'm gonna pull that up
so you guys can see it
can you highlight it um
i think it's right here i think i found
it that's so wild because
now knowing what we know went down in
that room
it's like he's saying he confirmed it
with his own eyes
that it did happen what is this it
doesn't work it's just like all choppy
you seen this yeah yeah i don't know
it's a weird export can you just time
stamp me or tell me where in the
interview it is yeah
something funky happened there adhd or
so this is the interview where it
happened the day after it was posted
um does anyone have a time stamp for me
the kb is working on it right you're
muted baby i'm not sorry i'm looking for
it right now
um i'll come back to that
so at any rate um i'll keep reading well
we look for that
uh dubrick went on to say that he was
always pretty good at asking his friends
for permission
always pretty
according to trisha like it was and seth
too
it was really like no he wouldn't take
no for an answer
right it was about coercion and
eventually paying them off
uh he was always pretty good at asking
his friends for permission to put their
quick
clickbait worthy moments in a vlog
there's no sex shown in the vlog but
hannah told insider what ended up being
portrayed in the video
about her was totally misconstrued
since it doesn't show the extent of her
intoxication which you know if they
actually showed that everyone be like
dude what the f
what dude what the f is this [ __ ] you
know what i mean yeah it would seem like
so
because i've seen behind the scenes
clearly he knew that video
and it's work dude that oh my god yo you
literally uh you were filming one of
your friends i think his name's dom
yes that's what i'm that's what i meant
by behind the scenes video yo so i want
to know that's all real
100 yeah yeah yeah uh you're talking
about my video
this morning uh yeah you just put out a
video this morning yeah i'm the biggest
david dover
like and subscribe you're talking about
the video i posted 20 minutes 20 minutes
ago before
i was just sitting in the bathroom
before you came over here um
yeah my uh my buddy dom made a instagram
story and he's like i wanna have a five
something night hit me up
and this girl hit him up and she's like
i have friends and she sent over all her
friends
instagram links and he's like yeah come
through and seven of them ended up
showing up
and then they all they were when they
all got there they were like oh no no i
don't have sex i don't have sex
and then like blatantly in front of in
front of everybody yeah yeah well yeah
they didn't have sex except except two
of the girls wanted to have sex
so we just ended up having a threesome
which was still his first three summon
it was very exciting for him so i
well you guys sent like three of your
friends in to confirm it was happening
yeah i mean
you know he didn't have sex with him
unless we unless we saw it with our own
eyes
so is that like is is dom your friend
that just
is he like the playboy of the group not
the playboy he's like
the gross like the gross kid who'll have
sex with anything
uh the predator
yeah it's all there man
she so she says they cut out the extent
of her intoxication
it seemed like i had a super fun night
with these famous vloggers basically
which is not
all what happened every single person i
know is messaging me oh you were in
david's vlog that's so cool or oh my god
i saw you in the vlog
on the day the vlog was released it was
viewed more than eight hundred thousand
times
people came up to hand in the library
and outline of the coffee shop to talk
about it she said
hannah said her little sister even
texted her about overhearing people at
hannah's old
high school talking about the vlog in
the bathroom it made hannah feel so
alone she said
it's difficult to describe how it feels
knowing that millions of strangers have
seen a video me
and the night that affected me and
traumatized me in nearly
incomprehensible ways
not knowing that anything was wrong
hannah said first time hannah said
she described what happened that night
as the r word she said she was in the
back of a cab in her hometown after a
night of drinking with friends
it was over winter break a month after
being filmed with the vlog squad the
next morning hannah said her friend
asked her if she was remember
if she remembers that she had a panic
attack in the car and she
started saying i was r-worded over and
over again on the way home
i don't want that to be my identity it's
not my identity i can comfortably say
though that i was the victim of
our word but i don't identify as a
victim hannah said that's just something
that happened to me
also that's why i didn't speak to anyone
about it for a long time
after she processed the events of the
night with the vlog squad hannah said
she did research about the legal system
of california
and decided it wouldn't be worth
pursuing a case because she was so
intoxicated at the time
but she still wanted to do something
on february 2nd 2019 pedes uploaded a
since deleted video accusing dobrik of
being an
actual horrible person who said she
along with nash exploited young women in
his vlogs
hannah watched the video and said it
made her wonder if other women also felt
objectified while filming with the vlog
squad
three months later after she last texted
dom hannah decided to reach back out
even after the vlog i think this is
even after the vlog was gone hannah
still struggled to find closure shortly
before midnight
on monday february 2019 hannah sent dom
a long text message so this text message
is really intense
this one's crazy intent we can you
highlight
um i'd rather just show the the image of
the message
you have that maybe i see i
don't but i'll let me see
i can start reading it like this but i
saw it on twitter
the whole thing i'd rather read it from
that
oh it's in cat's twitter thread that's
where we saw it yeah yeah yeah that
that's in here
so just pull that up real quick
cat is the author who is going to be
calling in
uh pretty soon
you get the medicine yeah um working on
it here's a link
to her tweet you posting it on discord
thank you
oh thank you okay here's the direct
message
perfect so
this is the message she sent back in
2019 early 2019
so you know if any if anyone wants to
say that this is like a cloud chase or
something this happened like two years
ago this message
well before she ever went public or
anything
she said hey dom if you remember me my
name is blank and we went through my
friend blank when you needed some girls
for your video
again that was the whole thing right
getting girls for for david's video
it's important to remember that because
david continually tries to
keep all the blame on dom yeah but
david is the one making money off of
this
absolutely i mean he and again remember
he thanked david
right on the night of november 25th my
friend and i came to your house to shoot
upon arriving i didn't intend to do
anything sexual with you or any vlog
squad member
and my tent was further reaffirmed when
i heard the sexist and demeaning
language of your team
within minutes of me being in your house
you pulled me aside into a separate room
and tried to initiate sexual behavior
with me one-on-one to which i
immediately
physically and verbally rejected to my
rejection you tried to make me feel
guilty and persuade me to hook up with
you saying come on
baby i'm blocking me from leaving the
room you made me feel very nervous and
uncomfortable especially because i was
away
from anyone i knew and because you were
an actual stranger i had never watched a
video of yours or anyone in the vlog
squad
after a few minutes of back and forth
between us i agreed to kiss you
so that i could leave the room and
return to my friends you let me leave i
rejoined my friends in the main living
room our one-on-one interaction
reaffirmed my initial feelings that i
did not want to participate in sexual
contact with any of the men in the room
as the night continued we chatted and i
was open to getting to know you as a
person
the last thing i remember is being
extremely drunk on your balcony
apparently you and your team brought me
hard alcohol that i drank
and you me and my friend blank had a
threesome which i have no memory of
whatsoever
to my understanding at some point during
the threesome i was too drunk and laid
on the bed and slept
from what i've been told my friends had
to come into the room and put on my
clothes and underwear bra shirt
shorts and shoes and i couldn't walk
leaving the house
before i left your house i threw up
several times in the bathroom as well as
in my own bathroom when i got home
according to one of my friends i was
passed out in your bathroom until she
pulled trig for me
when i got back to my dorm my friend
helped me throw again throw up again and
said i had no memory of what had just
occurred
when i woke up in the morning i had no
idea how to participate in any kind of
sexual action than i prior
it's two hours later when the same
friend mentioned the threesome to me
under the impression that i had
remembered at this point i was so drunk
when i sent you the text message
i was still drunk when i sent you a text
message saying you could put any clip in
the video that wouldn't be harmful to me
or an employer
at this point in time i don't feel the
same the video disturbs and upsets me
i did not feel like this is an accurate
portrayal of me and it's not something i
feel comfortable with being on the
internet anymore
it's incredibly disturbing to me to a
video online that documents an entire
night that i have no recollection of
and have everyone around me view me as a
reflected reflection of my character
especially
considering the mature content looking
back on the experience i have take i
feel taken advantage of as your friend
may have recognized
as the situation unfolded considering
according to my friend's memory
that people were joking about what is
what is and
is about what is
isn't consensual
is just a type of is and isn't
consensual that people were joking about
what
is and isn't consensual and the joke
about them going to jail at the end of
the vlog
these jokes and that [ __ ] show that
perhaps it was weighing on their
conscience once they saw how
incoherent and drunk i was after
patricia released her video i realized
that my experience and gut feeling of
discomfort being with you in that room
was not an isolated experience to me i
am reaching out now because it was taken
taken me a while to process what
happened i need for the video to be
taken down for my
own healing and peace of mind to which
dom simply responded okay i respect your
wishes the video
is down
which by the way unbelievable
which by the way means that this he had
a conversation because it was on david's
channel
right so he had to have a conversation
with david
explain why david needed to take down
the video so david
knew everything yeah that happened
he read this text message i'm assuming
for sure
i mean assuming or he he's i don't think
david would take down a video lightly
you know how can you just respond that
to somebody probably
dude this guy probably doesn't even
remember he's like oh just he probably
gets texts like this every day
he's like oh okay just another one of
those girls exactly
that are going to be difficult crazy dom
bro that's all you're gonna say did you
read this [ __ ] did you do you understand
what she's saying
okay he was basically just his response
was basically okay
okay his response was just k hey
[ __ ] dude shit's crazy man
anyway again hannah provided these
screenshots
to insider again this was two years ago
so like
why would she say this two years ago her
story hasn't changed
uh i read all this this is the
hannah said she was glad the vlog was
off dover's channel but she still deals
with
psychological effects of the night to
this day when she drinks she says she
still experiences panic attacks
sometimes
and she's having sex with a new partner
after jake and she said sometimes she
starts crying
uncontrollably i have nightmares where
i'm r-worded
and i'm not dreaming and when i'm not
dreaming i can't recall what dom's voice
sounds like or what any of their voices
sound like and when i have these dreams
i hear his voice
hannah said it's really [ __ ] weird
and disturbing knowing that somewhere in
my brain this incident is so alive
at the same time hannah says she was
processing her trauma
dom's appearance in the vlogs were
becoming less frequent and by the end of
2019 he had stopped
appearing entirely in november 2019
dom uploaded a video explaining why he
didn't appear on dobrick's channel
anymore
saying he wanted to pursue other
opportunities dom has since released
music
as dirty dom along with dobrik style
vlogs of his own
this goes on to say you know dom has
other accusations
uh before this happened
another youtuber this is the one i was
talking about ali
hardesty said that dom reached down her
shirt to grope her bare breast without
her consent in 2017
at a party he forcibly kissed her after
she repeatedly told him to stop
the same week the comedian elijah daniel
accused dom
of groping his friend three times
without consent so this is like
something he's just cruising around
doing apparently
so he posted an apology we can watch it
but
we can watch it i mean given all the
context i've got it here
it's still up an apology to
oh she clicked oh she linked it for this
what he did apparently
um and by the way david now delete it
not to
now just even a few days ago by the way
david's
comment on this video was still there
it is still there yeah it's still there
no way that's
wild so david responded let's see is it
still there
go down a little bit it's like oh my god
it's still there
he says proud of you dom being an idiot
is easy owning up to it is tough glad
you made this
um being an idiot
i don't know that necessarily describes
what he did
proud of you bruh
yeah he favored it by the creator i'll
thumb it up
what well you know bruh
i just want for visibility it's just
crazy that it's still here you know
i for visibility i'm gonna well the
dislike i want
if you dislike does it do anything if
you dislike i don't think so
i don't think how about no engagement no
engagement
so when was this apology video posted
because this whole three years ago
so prior to june 30th 2007 prior to what
happened in the
right because all of that happened in
2018 right so this was like
a year before maybe or maybe like eight
months before or something
it's short so i'll play it for you guys
just wanted to talk to you about some
stuff that's been going on with vidcon
overwhelming like majority by the
conversations made him including from
david was like great job buddy i'm so
proud of you
you're an idiot but we love you about me
so i just wanted to
make sure i got a story out there and
let everyone know what's going on
the accusations against me aren't 100
true but
to an extent they are um sorry
[Laughter]
okay
to what extent yeah to what extent are
they like to the extent of like
just up to here you touched it but like
past years
[Music]
to what extent are they true dude
crazy great job we're proud of you buddy
we're so proud of you i am aggressive
when talking to women i will say that
and there's a difference between being
forward and persistent
yo by the way clearly he didn't learn
anything no considering what happened
like six months later
but what i was doing was just too
intense
and now i'm working on that i've talked
to somebody intense and aggressive is
not a good way to describe your pickup
your style of picking up girls and
through their you know experience and
perspective on the situation you know
i i finally understand how disrespectful
i've been
first off i want to apologize to any guy
or girl that i've personally
disrespected myself
and from here on out um for all the new
people i meet and the people i
know i'm going to make sure to be
respectful second off i want to
apologize to my roommates
and friends that i create videos with
for bringing negative
bad energy into apologize to daddy
videos
i still want to be able to spawn
creative goofy videos
but i need to respect people's
boundaries more one of the issues i'm
addressing is filling people without
their permission
um there was a 15 year old girl that i
filmed having fun at a party it was an
18
plus event but regardless of her age
what i did was wrong because i didn't
ask her
permission to be in my content i
personally reached out to the people
i've disrespected in hopes that they'll
accept my apology and obviously i
understand that
this apology won't help fix the mistakes
that i made but
regardless i still wanted to put it out
there because it just needed to be said
and i needed to get it off my chest
yeah uh david dobrik proud of you dom
being an idiot is easy
owning up to it is tough glad you made
it special
you know what's really messed up you
know this just goes to show
how hard it is to come out um can you
find me the video
of the girl she some girl made a video
accusing dom of doing these horrible
things at vidcon
uh her video was like dislike bombed
people were calling her a liar
i sent a link to just a tweet that i saw
today that
was good a girl giving in after saying
no ten times is not consent
interesting
right you don't want you don't want to
co you don't
dude yeah it's not a [ __ ]
this is what people need to like get
used to understanding is
basically what you did to get her to
kiss all of them did
yeah they all did
it's like yeah you don't want to have
you don't want to have a
relations with somebody who's who
doesn't you need to
like convince to do it i mean david even
says it
in the vlog in the voiceover after
master negotiation
he negotiated his way in there by
so this girl put out this video and this
is why he's apologizing
look at the dislikes ela she probably
got a lot more from recent people
supporting her
but like she got [ __ ] on so hard clout
chaser all this [ __ ] and then dom's
video
he's getting massive amounts of love and
everybody forgives him
being an idiot is easy but owning it you
know
yeah i want to read some of these trashy
comments
she uploaded a part two as well
yeah hey guys so this okay well
i believe her i mean what's not to
believe
how far do you have to stretch your
imagination
uh
so anyway the apology
dobrick's comment apparently so the this
is dober
comment i wasn't sure what this the
significance of this was
um
hannah said finally
that of course it would be nice to get
an apology to get them to admit what
they did was wrong
i was exploited for content and stripped
of
my on my autonomy and a voice
so that's the article pretty pretty
pretty brutal damning [ __ ]
so then we get into
uh david's so-called apology video if
you can call it that i don't know
no you can't call it that
um before we get into that seth by the
way actually you know what let's watch
it first because it's in response
so get excited
now there's a lot to take away from this
first of all
it's called let's talk likes dislikes
and comments are disabled
okay i guess let's not talk i'll talk
you listen
let's talk it's posted on the views
channel which is by f
which is a brand new channel it has like
four videos on it
by far he's got a second channel he
wouldn't even posted that he's got david
dobrik too
not that one views why
views mo so transparently
yeah just because it has the least
amount of subscribers
yeah is trying to
be accountable by but at the same time
take zero accountability like it's crazy
the view it doesn't even make sense
there's like no rash like
two okay you'd be like okay it's a
second but putting it on view like
there's no logical
there's no justifiable explanation that
it would go on views
like what i don't think he tweeted it
out or anything
too so let's talk
oh by the way you want to see something
epicular you'll appreciate it
just want to show off what a hilarious
uh amazing
person i am that uh just want to
convince you that you did not make a
mistake
uh marrying me i never thought check
this tweet out
let's talk who can reply nobody
thank you let the conversation thank you
love that thank you thank you you want
to marry me again
i'll marry you again i'll renew my vows
girl anytime you want
all right let's talk guys get ready
david i want to come on here real quick
and address some conversations that have
been going on on the internet
um i you know i've made over 600 videos
and i've made a bunch of tick tocks
vines okay so don't cue the sales pitch
please
why does he bring this up why do you
think he brings up how many videos he's
made
okay yeah so oh seriously why do you
think he brings up
really really talented um i made 600
videos i get
hundreds i mean i don't know i think
that's his sales page
i think he thinks in a way it's an
excuse because he makes so many
so many videos something slip something
of course is going to happen
somebody of course is going to get r
worded over the course of 600 videos
little r word here a little essay there
we all make mistakes that's true we i
mean you know when you make that much
content like you're going
stuff is going to happen but like come
on dude
yeah um and i'm obsessed with what i do
i
love it it's weird to hear him not being
like what i do that's his sales pitch
you know when he talks to sponsors
they get this exact line right
i make 600 videos i am obsessed with
what i do i just want to make people
smile
it's weird to hear them not being like
oh
being able to make people happy for a
living and that's all that i want to do
um that being said consent is something
that's all i want to do but these people
are trying to stop me from doing it
these people are trying to stop me from
doing what i love deceiving
are you guys happy
dude i am so [ __ ] pissed that i can't
read the comments under this video
what are we going to do by the way nice
nickelodeon award behind him
oh my god
i just noticed that
[Applause]
kid's choice baby oh no
let's slime this guy bring out the slime
all is forgiven just give him a slime
it's all good
that's super super important to me
whether i'm shooting with a friend
or shooting with a stranger i always
make sure that whatever the video i'm
putting out i have
the approval from that person okay well
that's not what we hear from people
maury did a paternity test will not
claim and it's determined that to be not
true
not the father did that joke make sense
sort of a little bit you know there's
that meme where margot
that that was funny thanks zac i thought
this was good
oh bro trisha goes hey david dobrik
remember that night you asked to put in
a bit i didn't want and i said no and
you still put it in that's not consent
bud
love the bud oh shoot him with the bud
trisha's gotta be feeling good in that
not because
like this is all terrible things but
she's been [ __ ]
she her character has been bending
assassinated and being [ __ ] on and oh
yeah
and people not just david and his crew
but all of his fans saying all this most
horrible things about her
everything she [ __ ] said she still
gets it even now
i mean her their replies are very like
some people will
still be like stop being obsessed with
david
right this isn't being obsessed with
david
thank you well people say that to us too
but here's the thing
trust me we're not obsessed with david
look i'm just seeing this thing through
dude that's
it i never expected to go down this
rabbit hole i didn't even want to
interview seth originally
i was like i was done after big nick and
then
he told me to talk to seth and i was
like okay and that put us down this
rabbit hole that like i'm just gonna i
have to follow through
you know
so whatever but okay yes she yes she got
high on math and drove a car into his
house
right right
you know you remember the end of royal
tenon bombs
uh uh owen wilson's character gets high
on meth and crashes the car
into the party and runs over the dog i
don't really remember that he puts on
the indian
war paint the native american warfare
and i was like that was trisha
i think it was mescaline not meth but oh
man okay but the point stands
yeah it's the same whoa that's crazy
wow wow um and i also
acknowledge that those times where a
person can change their mind
and they decide that zach can you do me
a favor do you have some kind of sad
violin music
even just sad violin the song sad violin
the iconic one
thank you that's pretty good i get
annoyed at everything in this video even
now when he's saying
um i can understand that sometimes
people change their mind it's like even
that is kind of blaming
people and not himself also what are you
talking about yeah you know during
trauma people
kind of change their mind because it
takes them time to process what happened
to them
is that what you're talking about what's
going on in your vlog where people are
constantly changing their mind
like what are you putting people through
where they go oh you know what you did
well that was [ __ ] up and i don't want
to be in your video anymore he's like
yeah that happens
all the time hit me with that sad [ __ ]
it hit me with sad violin that's that
just it's different
the iconic it's called sad violin
yeah just hits on a different level dude
boomer memes
it's not boomer memes stop
sad violin it's different
you're out here calling me a boomer hey
at least be self-aware right
dude people are going to agree when that
assassin island hits look
zach can't even find it dude that tells
me how old you find it
you literally
i have all this other sad music i'm just
saying if you go to youtube it's
type sad violin do i need i'm just gonna
open it
i'm just going to play it on youtube in
the background watch this
i remember one time you told me not to
play that song look
sad violin 60 minutes of the sad violin
thank you how does this include paid
promotions
what the hell wait turn it turn it
significantly down oh really yeah it's
really loud
like way down yeah there you go that's
pretty good
see please continue
um and i also acknowledge that those
times where a person can change their
mind
and they decide that they no longer want
to be associated and no longer want to
be
in the video that i'm putting up and
then i'll take the video down
and there's also been moments where i've
looked back on videos
and i realized that these don't
represent me anymore and
they're hurtful you're just so great
david what is he talking about i wish he
would say what he's talking about it's
like
you want to have a conversation you want
to talk okay i'm going to stop the sad
music
you want to talk but you're not talking
about everything you're saying is super
ambiguous
you're making this huge sweeping
generalizations like people ask and i
remove i make videos i'm not
like if you want to talk let's talk
about what the [ __ ] you're talking about
and unpack it and if you really want to
grow and to learn on
then like what the [ __ ] is this
this is just and by the way if he has a
pr or legal or whatever this is such
a bad call mm-hmm he his response to all
this has been
the worst that every single turn right
starting with scotty right
and i wonder if that was just a result
of him being able to get away with
everything
his whole career i do think so i think
when someone gets away with stuff they
think
they're just going to continue to get
away i feel like
it probably went to his head he thinks
he can play everyone he thinks
well his even scotty said it's like my
policy is to never respond
and so he thinks like that's just they
don't acknowledge anything and so i
don't know
well they're like well it worked this
far so yeah they think it will work with
everything but
yeah it doesn't work with everything
they decide that they no longer
want to be associated and no longer want
to be in the video
that i'm putting up and then i'll take
the video down
and there's also been moments where i've
looked back on videos and like
i realized that these don't represent me
anymore like what
david they're hurtful are we talking or
not i don't i don't want them up because
i've
grown you know as a content creator and
as a person how are you going to take
accountability and not tell us what
you're talking about
like posted um with
the set situation i'm sorry to set okay
that
so because i like i said i
i just want to make videos okay so he's
sorry to seth despite
he still doesn't go into any detail yeah
what did what did you do to that sorry
no but despite the fact that he sent
texts assassinating his character
and just spreading him to scotty to make
a video about him where scotty said
he's a piece of [ __ ] yeah he luke he
wanted it a third time
yeah uh so david what kind of [ __ ]
apologies is to seth
when was claudia's video just a week ago
or yeah
it was a week ago so what the [ __ ] are
you apologizing for
which part or oh seth responded
i'll show that since we're at this part
seth responded he tweeted directly at
david
he said not calling me
to sincerely apologize man to man is
equivalent to having me kiss a man
without my consent i didn't understand
the analogy did
can someone help me
uh not calling me doesn't necessarily
apologize meant to admit
um i think he's saying that was a [ __ ]
apology
right like i get what he's saying but i
don't understand the equivalence
comparison but at any rate he is
confirming
that david did not call him it's like if
you were sorry to seth you would just
[ __ ] have called him even now i think
you could call him
but even even if he didn't
call just saying the way he says it is
just so not going into any detail he
doesn't explain anything it just doesn't
are you sorry that you pranked him the
first time the second time yeah like
what are you sorry for
can you can you just are you sorry that
he had to move to atlanta and pick up
his life
are you sorry that when he asked you to
remove the videos you offered to pay him
off instead of removing them
are you sorry that you sent his text
messages and the voice memo to scotty
and encouraged
scotty to make that video assassinate
his character which part are we sorry
for
for those of you guys who found
everybody invited i'm sorry you did for
those of you who didn't find it to be
offensive i'm sorry they did
wow i forgot about that one yeah he's
like yo i got away with that so
i could say anything whether you're
participating or watching
is enjoying and having a good time and i
miss the mark with that one
and i'm really sorry i truly truly am
um i feel like some there was a write-up
on our subreddit of someone who like
works with us
uh assault victims and she said he she's
met people like him
their theory was that david doesn't know
why he's apologizing
he doesn't understand what he did wrong
he doesn't know why he's apologizing and
that's why it's so
like nebulous and and like you don't
know what the [ __ ] he's talking about
and it's like
i'm sorry for this weird thing and it's
like
he doesn't know what he's apologizing he
doesn't think he did anything wrong and
so he doesn't know what he's apologizing
for it could be that but don't you think
too
like it it feels very like crafted by a
pr person to
like you kind of mentioned before not
necessarily tip people off
that aren't even aware of what the
accusations are
to what's going on i feel like i think
he's so obsessed with his own
success and fame and growth and that's
this is
all he wants is to be famous bigger more
famous more
money but it's like he doesn't even want
to say the r word
in association with his name he doesn't
even want to say you know anything that
really happened
because he's so scared of it being
associated with him
the problem is that this is a really bad
pr move
in my opinion because
because people are not stupid people are
going to want first of all the people
who are angry are going to be more angry
the people who don't know what he's
talking about are going to be curious
what the [ __ ] he's is he even talking
about so they're going to go read
if he you know um he's not doing himself
any favors unless he really thinks he
can just continue on afterwards like
maybe he can
maybe he's right you know what i mean
the [ __ ] do i know he's done it so far
with with people in my life that i don't
film with anymore
um like dom and you know the other
people that no longer film with i i
chose to distance myself
because i don't align with some of the
actions
and i don't i don't stand for any kind
of misconduct
and i i'm i was just i've been really
disappointed by some of my friends daddy
david disappointed separated from a lot
goes back to that great line from
scotty's video where he says
david doesn't have a bad bone in his
body he doesn't even get mad
he just gets disappointed daddy
daddy so he is basically just
shifting the blame to don all to dom and
saying
i don't stand with those actions right
well i think
david this is the legal defense where
it's like
this was all dom dom did the crime
that i i was just there i had nothing to
do with it but but obvious
it's so obvious from the account and the
story and everything
that david was the one that orchestrated
it he was it was just at my house and i
filmed it and it's on my channel
and i was telling everybody money from
it yeah according to trisha he was the
one that was encouraging guys to go buy
alcohol to get these girls drunk so that
they would
as one of the girls quoted do something
sexy you know what i mean
you guys are so boring done for the
content for your channel
dom thanks david he said thanks for
setting this up
he said thank you david the guys peeking
into the bedroom when they were having
sex said i have to confirm for the vlog
david said on the podcast that happened
like
the next day after he posted the day of
he said you know we have to go in and
confirm the head count for the vlog
so what exactly which part are you
trying to
avoid responsibility for exactly
you know it was just dumb
or are you saying that you didn't know
dom was a predator when you commented
under his last video how proud you were
of him
for owning up to assaulting somebody
i mean if anything he created this
really unsafe situation for those girls
he should have known better letting dom
go along with them
when everyone was drunk yeah he should
have known he should have known
that he's putting the girls in a
situation that's not safe for them well
he wanted that to happen for content
and he cut out the part where the girl
was black out drunk yeah
to make it look and according to the
girl they even went back and reshot some
scenes to make it look so more
happy-go-lucky
right
i think with any video i make my main
purpose
is to make people happy and and inspire
people and
i just i never want anything to get in
the way of that
i'm sorry if i let you down and things
like that won't happen again
and i learned from my mistakes um and i
also believe that actions
speak a lot louder than words and you
know you can take my word for it i'm
going to change but i'll also show you
and i'll prove to you that what are you
changing you didn't what are you
changing you just
blame dom you distance yourself you're
disappointed
you did apologize to seth i don't know
what exactly for so i don't know what
he's pledging to change exactly
the mistakes i made before won't be
happening which are
yeah by the way just a little close up
brought to you by kids choice awards
2021 kids choice for boys
kids choice award nickelodeon get slimed
idiot
get inspired
free victory
yeah he's got crazy lawyers involved but
they're not doing any [ __ ] help man
maybe they're just really worried about
actual legal
um legal issues and they're trying to
just
because he you know there he's he's
definitely
exposed to a lawsuit from seth and this
girl so
maybe they're just trying to keep him
from like losing everything i don't know
so also there was an interesting little
uh
similarities david issuing an apology i
guess people were
when seth originally i made
his video calling out david like a few
years ago
david made some kind of apology and
you'll notice how many similarities
there are between this apology and the
last one um i you know i've made over
600 videos jason and i have made i don't
know over 6 700 videos together
i couldn't even tell yes and i've made a
bunch of tick tocks
vines instagram stories tweets the whole
thing um and i'm obsessed with what i do
i love
being able to make people happy for a
living and that's all that
i want to do every every video i make
every instagram
i post everything i do i just want to
cheer somebody up i want to make videos
where everybody in it you know whether
you're participating or watching
is enjoying and having a good time and i
miss the mark with that one
i want them to have a positive
experience when they're interacting with
anything i produce and with that being
said i feel like on a handful
of occasions i've just missed the mark
on that that's exactly the same
pretty interesting right it's like he
copy pasted his apology from whatever pr
firm yeah
the first time missed the mark
just want to make people happy that's
all by the way
especially the bankers handling my bank
account
i just want to make my lawyers happy all
right well we've got cat
the author of the article on call
so let's let's talk to her all right
give me one second i'll bring her and
let's see if she has anything to add to
the conversation just
ask her some questions i'm i have some
questions for her
she did a really good job on this
um from a journalistic standpoint i mean
well sourced well researched
slam dunk
all right one second you get your
medicine lender in the lobby
you're still waiting so do we need to go
pick it up
um no i think we will get it delivered
sick eagle's hand oh she's there i see
her
hey can you hear me
yeah i can how are you hi um let me pin
you so
yeah so dan is everything all good with
your side before it looks good
can you pin her or do i need to do that
oh
uh i got you okay thanks
thank you
can the audience see her fine should i
just start okay
cat first of all well well done on the
article
thank you so much thank you for reading
it um i really appreciated hearing all
of your thoughts going through it and
going through all of like the receipts
that
the accusers provided and your reaction
to the
to david's video response i thought was
really spot on am i going to be in
trouble with insider for pirating your
premium
members only article no i mean you know
your fair use law really well
thank you so tell me how first of all
how did you get um
interested in writing this story because
i didn't know
i mean i've been pretty following all
the vlog squad stuff
and i had no idea about these
accusations so how did it come across
you
yeah so honestly after
um you guys started interviewing past
vlog squad members
um the insider digital culture team we
started just kind of digging
into the various people who had been a
part of the vlog squad and like we
started talking to
um both like the former group members
who had come forward to you guys and
then also
other people who have been involved with
the group and
from like our conversations with those
people and our conversations with people
who have just like reported on and are
familiar with
the vlog squad um we were able to find
out
essentially that there was this accuser
who wanted to be anonymous but who had
this really dark story
um so i ended up getting connected with
her
hannah in the story a couple weeks ago
and initially
i figured that hannah's story would be a
part of a much
larger look at just like the culture
created by the vlog squad
but then when scotty posted his video
um i just was like oh my gosh they're
trying to shift
the narrative before we even get a
chance to see the extent of what people
have again so do you think you think the
scotty
video was in response to your team
and you inquiring with them did they
know that you were working on this story
that wasn't in response to us because we
had not reached out to anybody
um at that point but i did think just
having heard hannah's story already and
having that in the back of my mind
i was like there's so much like dark
stuff that has yet to come out about
this group and then when scotty put a
video out and initially
um i remember like scotty's video when
it first dropped
all of the responses were like his own
fans yeah it was really positive
and i thought there was like a real
danger that just this very like as you
guys have both
spoken about it like scotty's statement
i was afraid it had the
ability to make it no longer like a good
environment to release hannah's story
into
um because i think part of the i think
the timing was so important with this
story
um like if hannah had come forward a
couple years ago when
david was still producing vlogs
regularly and everybody was obsessed
with him
i feel like she and whatever publication
ran it would have had a really hard time
um with like defending her and the
reporting from all of david's supporters
but right now it just felt like there
was a moment
um and this was the right time for
people to unpack like something so
severe
yeah i think you're right about that i
mean as we pointed out dom's first
accuser made a video and she got
absolutely
destroyed and dom was allowed even by
david himself in the comments as like
great job dude owning you know your
assault
yeah yeah i think the alley hardesty
thing is so
fascinating um and ally's video
like obviously like you said it was
dislike bombed and
i know a lot of people have spoken about
how that impacted the trajectory of her
career on youtube
but it also empowered other survivors to
come forward because
um like i know hannah had like seen that
video
so it was sort of like this culmination
of like the more things that come out
about the vlog squad the more people are
kind of starting to feel more
comfortable saying
oh like i can talk to my experiences as
well
i think it like makes people feel less
alone um
and then also just in terms of what
people define as those types of
experiences
i think a lot of people tend to doubt
themselves um especially
in the immediate aftermath it's kind of
like well maybe i'm the one who had it
wrong like maybe
i should have done something else in the
situation and it takes like multiple
people coming forward and saying
actually the responsibility falls on dom
and david and the rest of the
famous adults there um to not put
like strangers in a situation like that
how was i know you had a lot of back and
forth with david's lawyers
how was that experienced was the team
ever close to
did they ever were persuasive and like
i know they were probably trying to stop
the publication of the article
altogether
um were they close to succeeding in
doing that
um i wouldn't say that i would say like
obviously what's important in the
reporting process when you have
allegations like this
is bringing forward all of the claims to
the other side so they have an
opportunity to respond
and like flesh out like even if
minor details in the story were pointed
out as like inaccurate then that would
be super important because ultimately
the central claim is supported by all of
those tiny details of what else happened
that night
so like in the reporting process i
reached out to every single member
of the vlog squad who was there i
obviously reached out to trisha
i reached out to everyone who's
associated with david and then i also
individually reached out to
like brandon calvillo and nick antonian
and jeff whitake and
everyone else who was on camera at that
point um
and i think like with what david's
lawyer eventually
gave us as a statement to put in the
article it's you know pretty clear that
essentially they just wanted to reduce
how much of like the responsibility
would fall on david
right um but i think especially with the
central claim the fact that like it was
dom
who ultimately is being accused of this
act um
the fact that he didn't have a response
to it and still has not had a response
to it
is really interesting to me um it makes
me wonder since he put out that video a
couple days ago
if like dom will have a response at any
point that video is kind of weird now
it's almost like he was trying to shift
the story before the article came out
yeah and that was so strange to me
because i had
reached out to him um where with that
text message that hannah had sent to him
when she sent me that like she also sent
me the number
like that dom had responded with so i
just like flat out texted him
um and this was a day or two before his
video came out and i said like hey is
this dom
um i think i tried to call him and he
like didn't pick up and he was like who
is this and i was like this is a
reporter like is this dom
um and he was like immediately without
me even initially telling him what the
claims were
he was immediately like i won't be
speaking to any publications
until i put out a video um i was like
what is this video even gonna be about
he didn't know he didn't know
what was the focus of your story when he
put it there
and then the next morning i like emailed
him everything and then oh
god got it
so he probably thought you were just
trying to
get a comment on what he thought about
everything going on
he didn't realize the gravity of of of
all this coming down on him yeah
yeah the timing and the everything he
said was just so bizarre
knowing uh and then now especially
looking back at it
um are there more
stories coming out is this like your big
scoop i know you've been working on a
lot on the vlog squad is there more to
follow
yeah we're definitely still working on
like other leads
um that we kind of started tugging at in
the process of investigating this one
um and i do definitely think that there
will be more to come from our team
on this topic with this one i was
particularly just like
hannah's story is so shocking like it's
so severe i was like this has to come
first and on its own so that nobody can
be distracted from like
what this woman experienced especially
with it being
such a part of the vlog it's it is so
shocking
it's just crazy and and so what do you
make of the
like that she says that she thinks that
some of the scenes were shot at a
different date
yeah for example the one where dom comes
out all sweaty and he's like thanks
david
what do you make of that what what was
what do you
what was your guys's kind of
guess of why they did that yeah and
when the both hannah and then her friend
sarah when both of them were talking
about
this idea that some of the scenes were
re-shot it all kind of tied back
to um what they said to hannah in
particular
she felt like the whole vlog
misconstrued
which is the same thing that seth i
think said like it was just this idea
that david
in his editing had like misconstrued
what really happened that night
um and particularly like you see the
guys opening the door
like poking their heads in and then when
you see dom and he's like drenched in
sweat
um i think like the image that's
conjured up in the viewer's head is like
oh like
it was a success it was it was positive
in some way like it's super skeezy but
like
positive for dom um but also like you'll
notice that the girls aren't there
anymore
that's what i was gonna say yeah yeah
they've just been completely cut out of
the narrative at that point
and i think like to me especially in
retrospect but even at the time
it's just like regardless of whether
these women were famous or not
regardless of whether what happened was
consensual or not
like you're choosing to only tell the
narrative from like the male
perspective the women are literally just
props
for sure and then and i think it really
shows
um the
level of i guess involvement on david
david's part because it shows that he
had a narrative he was trying to put
together
for his vlog and they even had to go and
reshoot a scene to make it fit the
narrative
and i don't think that's even a stretch
to assume i think he's known
even amongst his friends and publicly
that he's
super committed to making sure these
vlogs follow through
and he's got this preconceived plot line
because
yeah if he if he just showed what
happened after it would have looked
awful
right like the girls one can't even
stand up
yeah they're puking in the bathroom yeah
they could have never showed that that
wouldn't have been funny at all
no right yeah i think david's even
either described himself or some of his
friends have described him as more of
like a director
which i think it has like a really
interesting connotation to it because
the idea that david is directing the
narratives of his vlogs it makes sense
um and then i think a lot of people have
said
i think especially following the article
why do you even need to mention david
like
why does david have to be a part of
these accusations like he
isn't accused of hurting anyone so why
even mention it all
and it's like well david is if he's the
director
then it's like he is the one who
facilitated all this
and that's what hannah said basically
like a direct quote from her was i feel
like david
in a lot of ways facilitated mine well
it's especially interesting when you
consider like okay let's assume that
she's right and they
re-shot this scene when dom comes out
all sweaty so that means that under
david's direction
bomb thanked david which obviously
implies that david had done something to
make this threesome happen for him
right which they specifically re-shot
which it's just it's really interesting
that uh
how they chose to to convey that
but i have to say i mean as far as
articles go with these kinds of
me too moments and these kinds of
accusations is that
there's always just enough room to
question
the accusations and the motives but but
i feel like in the way that you guys
were
able to source this and write it and the
amount of evidence that
the victims were able to um provide you
yeah
is i don't see anyone even doubting the
accounts and so i congratulate you on
that
um really excellent write-up and a
fantastic job um
with your sources and uh really well
written and i think you did a fantastic
job there so
great work thank you so much yeah that
means a lot
um cat 10 barge
10 bart they said the name right
cat 10 barge is the author of this
article with insider you can
find her on uh uh twitter what's your
twitter
sorry i'm not prepared yeah
yeah we look forward to whatever comes
next from you so fantastic work and
thank you for calling in we appreciate
it
yeah thank you thank you guys for having
me thanks scott
bye thank you cat hey
so um
mom so wild
we said it all we did it all yeah
she did an amazing job i have to say i
agree i didn't know what to expect but
like
that was a slam dunk especially through
reading everything it's like everything
is a link to
the actual what they're talking about
you know
oh this was the video you didn't see
that i wanted to show you so i don't
know if you remember this but you ran
into david
in a bathroom and you threw hands with
them
i feel like that's what you look like
fighting
you see what i meant about the sweater
you're wearing
lena's watched that a million times oh
my god i just hear her laughing
yeah just cracking up with that watching
that
is that what you do if you saw david did
you throw
no i don't i'm not you're not i'm not
into violence but i think that's a
really funny video
it could be you i mean we don't know oh
whoa what a weird coincidence i just saw
what you shared a b
this article yeah i don't know if we
want to show his face but i find the
timing interesting that is very
interesting timing because we just
talked about this you see
wait wait i recognize this guy's face
the guy is the guy who spotted you guys
he got sentenced oh that's him yeah yeah
this is a new 30 minutes ago
he was sentenced to three years in
prison oh i don't mind showing it
i think we've showed it before i think
when we initially talked about it yeah
three years for attacking journalists
university historic church and some
uh [ __ ] dumbass youtuber apparently
that's me what a guy huh
no wonder he's pretty much exactly what
you would expect
that guy to look like that's kind of
scary only three years
yeah i know like okay well whatever
enjoy and whoever did it yesterday enjoy
a few a glimpse into your future
hopefully yeah
um so that's about that
thank you guys for tuning in to an
important episode here
yeah and um we will be back
as usual on friday for after dark live
thank you for coming and sitting in this
episode of we're happy to have you oh
yeah i mean
this topic is um one that i find very
interesting and i
just i mean i i am kind of
not happy but i'm kind of happy that we
can like
give platform to this topic because i
think it's so important
it's nice the people there's just so
much misinformation about this kind of
stuff
and the more people get educated on it
the better
it's so it's so messed up to look at
this one girl like from back of vidcon
who made this video about how dom
assaulted her and then everybody's like
[ __ ]
this girl she just wants it's like it's
so messed up it's
nice and even
look even david was trying to do the
same thing with seth so it's nice
to give these people
the credibility they deserve and these
people are credible you know what i'm
saying like these people these are
credible accusations
can't be more credible mm-hmm
um i never thought we would get to such
a
heavy accusations yeah totally not
this this like the set thing is horrible
but
yeah but this is really i mean no the
set thing is really horrible like i
don't want it i don't want it to demand
we started with the big
stuff which was more i just i mean said
that to move across country yeah the
[ __ ] like his experience was really
just didn't i guess i didn't really
think there was going to be more
you know but i mean who knows what else
is out there
like he said we made hundreds of videos
600 videos 600 videos what else is in
there
yeah good point david we'll keep digging
anyway guys we'll see you on friday
thank you for watching
thank you thank you thank you this is a
serious message to everybody watching
my update video right now peace and love
peace and love i want to tell you please
after the 20th of october no more
fan mail and no objects
to be signed if there's a date on the
envelope
it's going to be tossed i'm warning you
with peace and love i have too much to
do
thank you thank you we're missing
something
all right we'll see you on friday
everybody
thanks bye bye bye
[Music]
so
[Music]
you